what up guys welcome to the just pearly
famous youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to kevin samuels show
from last night a lot of you said that i
should react to um the fifth caller on a
show so that's what i'm gonna do before
i start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos as you guys know i'm
moving to england in a couple weeks
and i'm nervous like it's going to be a
lot so every subscriber really helps me
support the channel and support me to my
move with my move to england okay
ready
hello
hi
how are you
i'm good
good
uh are you on youtube or something
no i'm on my laptop
okay
um
well let's just focus on our how old are
you
i'm 27.
all right so what question do you have a
comment
um
well my comment is
um
if you're saying you know the danger
zone
and to get a high value man at this time
um
how could
we
how could i juggle it with getting a
high value man back
that um i felt like i lost because i
wasn't
um in therapy i wasn't
um
i wasn't ready and he called it out he
said i needed to get therapy
and
i really want him okay
you know what i am glad you asked this
question
how to fix it
okay
but first off
you've already done step one
acknowledging that there is a problem
acknowledging that you found somebody
that could be in the area
and
let's just say it nicely you might have
screwed it up
right
how to get it back
um
well is the person still single and
available
yes
okay so so far so good um
i think it's good to like acknowledge
when you messed up in a relationship i
have always thought
that a lot of people would
get back together with exes um
or even like messed up friendships
whatever it is but just like giving a
heartfelt apology and like
admitting that they were wrong a lot of
the time um i don't think you see that
often
okay
approximately how long ago
did you guys end your interaction
a year ago but he doesn't live in the
same state as me
okay
a year ago
all right and he ended it
by saying it was ended he said that you
need to get your your stuff together
he said literally i need to get therapy
have you done that
yes i've been in therapy from that time
so yes i'm i'm still in therapy
all right and
have you learned anything in therapy
that would have made a difference
in the relationship you had
yes that i have to go from what i see
right now
i can't go off of
what i've done in the past and i
shouldn't bring it up
because he doesn't know about that
either and
it was always i i felt like i was giving
him too much information where he would
be it's like i don't care i don't want
to talk about that and i was like
thinking he was mean but i should never
brought those things up because it
didn't matter
okay so he didn't donate
making men in your present pay for
mistakes of your past equals no future
that's what she's saying number one
number two i think that's really true um
like i think that's the biggest mistake
you can make
with people to be honest is making
you know what i mean like the next guy
didn't do anything to you so why does he
have to pay for something the last guy
did
when men are ready to move forward they
really don't care
about
all that stuff they just want to know is
it a problem
so
uh when was the last time you spoken to
this man since your breakup
um i haven't just over a year since that
time but it since all that has passed
um and i felt like i lost him i i moved
on
and
i got married but i don't want to be
you got married wait
yeah wait currently married
yes wait oh yes oh
no no oh my
wait wait
like thinking what do you mean but i
should never brought those things up
because it didn't matter i always wanted
to see this ring
he didn't do anything
making
a platform with a million folks
so he didn't do anything
making men in your present pay for
mistakes of your past equals no future
that's what she's saying number one
number two
when men are ready to to move forward
they
your eggs
because he's high valued okay sorry guys
i'm not meaning to like
yeah
you currently
oh my gosh why can't i get it okay sorry
when was the last time you spoken to
this man since your breakup
um i haven't just over a year since that
time but it since all that has passed
um and i felt like i lost him i i moved
on
and i got married but i don't want to be
you got married
yeah
you're currently married
yes
oh yeah no oh my gosh that looks like a
nice ring too oh no
oh you gotta be kidding me
ma'am
get it kevin get her you telling me
no i'm not you broke up this guy called
it out and instead of and you said you
wouldn't gotten to happy
and you're married
and you're actually you're actively on
a platform with a million folks actively
talking about
leaving your husband to get back with
your ex like lady at least turn the
camera off
what are you doing
because he's high value and i look like
and you fumbled the bag miss
move on
look at kevin's face
look at his face
go ahead
yeah he's high value and
with um
even with watching you it's kind of
taboo my husband is 25 years older than
me
and so
i would want to be with
this other high value man because he's
only about 15 years older than me so
and what does your husband do for a
living
he's a pipe fitter he works at a
shipyard
how tall are you
i'm five seven
dress lines
i'm a size four to six
so i'm i'm hearing you correctly you're
with a previously high value man who was
15 years older than you
yes and you
kind of ruined that relationship ran
into a ditch
he suggested therapy
um
and you came in saying you wouldn't got
therapy
but and also in that course of time you
just
you've moved on
and you got married
to a man who's 25 years older than you
yes
and the reason you want to
[Music]
um
break your covenant with god
uh
and wreck your home
of the pipe fitter guy
is because the previous guy was higher
value meaning he earns more money
yeah and
his social status
how he looks um
virginia
or which part dmv
um
yeah this lady is wilden
oh my god i hope they play this in her
divorce court yeah
hold on just a second
and what does the first guy do for them
some cyber security he and he has his
own business
um
so i want you to ask yourself a question
what did it say about it what do you
think it would say to that man
about a woman who
willingly got married to an older man
and she was willing to leave her husband
with a shot at getting back with him
what do you
think that would say to him
that she is determined
and she knows what she wants
read the room
read the room sis
well it would be willing to give up
something
like something greater
and
i honestly know that
being with my husband now it was to say
yeah i'm still a decent woman and you
know men do want me but i wanted to pick
the right one that's able to do
something for me and i always wanted
older men
because uh
that
so if we switched this situation
and it was a man
who ruin this situation with a
with a woman
uh
and
he decided to get the therapy that he
needed
and get married to another woman
but then he would be willing to leave
his current wife to get back with the
previous woman what would the world say
about that man
that he's trash that's what they would
say they would say the man is trash
he's just trading you in for a younger
model he'd like use the second girl they
would say that this woman he got back
with
is the one he always wanted
she belongs to the streets
i just felt like he's not even being
ready i'm just glad he told me how old
are you again man i'm 27.
um are you from this country yes
do you have any siblings
yes
i mean
i have three and i'm the youngest
uh any sisters
yes one sister is she married
yes
what did she say about it
i i don't talk to my sister
what would your father say about it
my father he was against me marrying um
no no what did your father say about you
talking about leaving your husband to go
back to your ex-boyfriend
well he said that my husband gave me a
home
and that you know a young
man won't do that and i should
appreciate that because he he yeah
you would think
again
well i'm going to go ahead and be honest
with you man
i've heard some pretty interesting
things in a year and a half
of doing this show
but um
you probably have to be probably the
problem the worst woman i've ever spoken
to
what wow oh my gosh yeah
i've heard a woman that actually
surprisingly he his tone is fine
here you can talk about his face he
means every word was going to leave her
but at least she waited for her husband
to be in remission before she left him
i was hoping you were trolling but the
more you talk the more realistic you are
so i honestly hope whoever knows this
woman's husband make sure he watches
this video
leave her ass leave her ass
you can do better king
that's so embarrassing
oh my god for both of them modern women
ladies and gentlemen
modern women
you heard it
you heard it all
and you wonder why men are hesitant
apprehensive
outright descend to hell with it
i'll make you famous
[Music]
you heard it
hi
how would a woman like me get back with
my high value x
you know you know and
million plus 1.2 million subscribers she
didn't even say turn off the camera
oh my gosh
how can i get back with my
boyfriend
but in order to do that i'd have to do
i'd have to divorce my older husband
who's married me and provided for me but
he's just a pipe fitter
the other guy is fitters make hella
money too younger in a better
socioeconomic position and he looks
better
how would that look if it would flip the
genders well they would say that that
that man knows what he wants
oh my god
i think there's a um
let's do this real quick
um
let's do this real quick because it's
something i actually posted
um
on instagram
i think this is a good time to kind of
pull this up right now because
oftentimes people tell me you're so
harsh on the women
and the women this and the women that
and they don't deserve this kind of
treatment
and you know and i i'm always talking
about how such a staunch advocate for
men
um
yeah
but i'm often told how bad i am
how bad i am so
yeah
yeah yeah let's go ahead and uh do this
real quick though
yeah you guys heard all that all right
sociopath
a person or personality disorder
manifesting yourself in extreme
anti-social attitudes or behavior or
lack of conscious
the anti-social personality disorder
called aspd
description a mental health disorder
characterized by disregard for other
people those with anti-social
personality disorder may begin to show
symptoms of childhood but the kids the
condition can't be diagnosed until the
adolescents or adulthood
i posted on instagram oh about a week
ago
and i said
the interwebs has been graced with a
higher rate of madness as of late let me
just leave this right here
now while i may not be a medical or
clinical professional i do study the
human brain
sociology psychology
i'm fascinated with how minds work
um
i stay in my lane but i do think we're
seeing a rise
in psychopathy
it wasn't even like she didn't have like
a dad to like
model for her like this is crazy um i
mean so sociopathy not psychopathy not
psychopath sociopath
uh and then narcissism
uh i'll leave that to the professionals
[Music]
but you could see the low affect there
the complete lack of empathy
uh
i don't
think that she and honestly i don't
think she even registers what was wrong
he was and i would tell you honestly
from my standpoint
people like her
often come to
places like this and they kind of gauge
your response and the appropriateness of
their response based upon you
that's why a lot of you guys are
probably in the chat room like oh my god
he's about to do it i'm like no i'm just
gonna i'm going to give her nothing to
react to
give her nothing to react to so her
so her uh
her personality
she wouldn't have any way to mirror
because if i'd have been like oh my god
you're such and so forth oh my god no
i'm not horrible but when i said i think
you're probably about the worst person
i've dealt with she just shut down she
had nothing to mirror so don't act as
don't think that i don't know what i'm
doing over here
i'm not just a guy in a suit
and i think it is extremely valuable for
men and women
to highlight
some of the things that are actually
floating around some of the attitudes
that are floating around out here in
modern mating and dating so maybe you
ladies can start
understanding just a bit
some of the challenges that men are
dealing with when it comes to trying to
pick a mate
okay i'm gonna end it there yeah
that was crazy
at first i was like sis you did good you
know you've been oh shoot you've been
you're recognizing that you were the
problem
you're trying to do better in the future
but nah
oh my gosh this lady was just crazy let
me know in the comments guys let me know
um
what did you think don't forget to
subscribe please subscribe ring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time